the current governor of the fan boat
accident state is rick Scott who is
actually is actually what looks like if
you shave down Guy Fieri for the summer
it looks like me with a bad infection
[Laughter]
are you actually with Howie Mandel is
actually Rick Governor Rick Scott no you
look healthy he looks like a wing with
gargoyle cast out of hell he looks like
Gollum stepdad or Jack or Jack
Skellington and tan face or I've been
told the Millennials in the audience
might not appreciate this one uh but he
looks like the lead singer midnight oil
can we just play some Floridians really
really really just like this walking
seal penis like the angry citizen who
set up a website called Rick Scott sucks
but there is someone all Floridians do
love I am referring of course to musical
superstar pitbull Miami native it looks
like a look like yeah that's after
the after
well anyway last night's Home Run Derby
mr. worldwide ended up trending
worldwide thanks to his tot tucked in
National League all-star Jersey hey
Pablo Shaffer yes there's nothing more
American than pitbull in a baseball
jersey Florida need a new leadership to
United State maybe he should run for
governor so comedians what would be the
gubernatorial candidate pitbulls
campaign slogan will be yes David
pitbull for governor get who gives a
alright fine
paid for by we're all gonna die ha hey
Murray Biffle you know you want him
he knows you want jobs yes fine
[Applause]